the force awakens you know in a lot of
ways was a movie for fans and to bring
people back to that to the origins story
by Episode nine do you see it being
really different and just taking us to
tons of new places you know a story must
evolve or perish and and Ryan and I are
working closely together to make sure
that our stories build off of each other
and continue to evolve and take us to
new places and I think that's what the
fans expect and what they want there are
petitions to bring George back how do
you react to those petitions uh you know
I was it was funny I saw that I think it
was yesterday and it was on a day where
I was at Lucasfilm giving this big
speech to everyone about how we want to
channel the the invention and it's the
raw creativity and the boldness that
George brought to these films and that's
something that I'm so focused on and not
being afraid that we're gonna embarrass
ourselves by doing something that might
be crazy because when George Lucas made
Star Wars
a lot of people thought it was crazy but
it's the greatest story ever told